لقبوني بنيوتن غزه الشبه اللي هو بينه
وبين نيوتن انه نيوتن يعني هو قاعد تحت
شجر التفاح وق عليه التفاحه فاكتشفت
الجاذبيه واحنا في ظل الظلام اللي احنا
عايشنا فيه والماساه والصواريخ يعني بتنزل
علينا ف انا فكرت اني اعمل هذا الضوق
اخترعت هذا
الضوق احنا يعني نزحنا من الشمال لرفح في
مخيم يعني اول 20 يوم احنا عشناهم يعني في
الظلام يعني في الليل في ظلام يعني انا
حزنت على امي وعلى ابويا وعلى اخواتي انه
في ظلام دامس احنا بنعيش فيه في الليل ف
فكرت انه اعمل هذا الشي انه يخفف من
المعانات اللي احنا عايشين فيها رحت على
سوق الخرده في الاول فلقيت هدول المراوح
جبتهم فكرت انه اعمل فيهم طحونه هوائيه
يعني تولد الطاقه اول محاوله ما زبطت معي
الثانيه كانت و الطاقه بس ضعيفه الثالثه
جبت كمان واحده وركبتها فوقيها ويعني ضبطت
بعدين نزلت منهم اسلاك و يعني ضويت منهم
ضوء فيعني ضبطت الفكره شعوري يعني انه انا
لما اكتشفت انه هذا الفكره اللي انا
عملتها ضبطت اكيد كنت مبسوط كثير يعني انه
خففت معاناه عن اهلي وعن امي وعن ابوي
المريض وع اولاد اخوي الصغار يعني خففت
كثير من المعاناه والازمه اللي احنا
عايشين فيها في
الحرب